au large d'assos la grèce paraît si
proche si facile à atteindre
une impression trompeuse pour les
milliers de migrants qui viennent ici
rêvant de l'europe et d'une nouvelle vie
on les voit partout embusqué dans la
forêt attendant le signal de départ des
passeurs à qui ils ont donné des
milliers de dollars parfois ce sont les
gendarmes turcs qui sévissent et essaie
de les chasser
parfois c'est la météo qui vont
contrecarrer leurs plans
l'attenté peut être longue les no sleep
nancy
ça fait cinq jours que je suis ici et
que je ne dors pas nous dit c'est
iranien forcé de quitter le bois avec
son groupe alors que le jour tomber mais
ils reviendront demain après demain le
plus vite possible
le lendemain matin la mère s'annonce
plus calme nous essayons donc d'aller à
la rencontre de notre groupe sur le
point de partir en mer que notre chemin
a vite été barré par cet homme mécontent
de l'attention que suscite ce qui se
passe sur sa terre je ne les aide pas se
défend t-il alors que nous le film on à
son insu leur pays est en ruine
ils ne font que passer par ici et laisse
mes champs couverts de déchets avant
d'être évincé nous remarquons pourtant
dans la remorque de son tracteur
quelques gilet de sauvetage bien emballé
ce que le vieil homme préféré cacher le
voici
alors que le vent se lève et les vagues
se font de plus en plus forte
un premier groupe se met à l'eau depuis
chez lui rapidement le bateau prend
l'eau et son pilote un migrant lui même
peine a dirigé l'embarcation une
deuxième embarcation se lance avec
autant de difficultés le vent et les
vagues sont telles que la plupart des
pêcheurs dans la petite ville d'assaut
ce malgré leurs années d'expérience au
large de leurs embarcations beaucoup
plus adéquates ont décidé eux de rester
à quai dans le port des pêcheurs observe
une scène de détresse qui l'on trouve
souvent vus ils sont inquiets au point
de contact et les garde côtes turques
après avoir accosté un des bateaux
gonflables ils reviennent vers la côte
avec un avertissement
ouah coup de semonce sans se décourager
les prochains malgré les avertissements
de dame nature et de la garde-côtière un
troisième bateau a tenté la traversée
depuis ce matin mais visiblement dans ce
cas ci les passagers ont décidé de
rebrousser chemin
incapable de ramener le petit zodiac à
son port d'attache le groupe parvient
quand même à atteindre la rive speaking
les abords des afghans surtout quelques
pakistanais et un africain qui ne veut
pas dire d'où il est exactement
je ne sais pas ce qui est arrivé je
retourne à istanbul dit il c'est trop
risqué j'ai une famille je ne vais pas
retourner
j'ai peur je ne sais pas nager alors je
ne retournerai pas à l'eau c'est fini
cet ancien soldat des forces spéciales
afghanes nous mîmes ce qui est arrivé ça
vaut sans doute mieux comme ça les
naufrages en mer egée se multiplient à
un rythme alarmant selon john john key
il ya de l'émotion de ces pêcheurs turcs
sont en clairement ils ont peine à
croire que ce bambin qu'ils extirpe
d'une mère froide soit toujours en vie
avec une douce maladresse ils tentent du
mieux qu'ils peuvent de réconforter le
petit qui sera réuni avec sa famille
dans les heures qui suivent cette
histoire-là finit bien
mais pour des dizaines et des dizaines
d'autres qui ont risqué la traversée au
même moment le périple s'est avérée
fatale sur l'île grecque de lesbos les
corps continuent d'être rejeté par les
vagues
on ne compte plus les enterrements de
ces anonymes qui au lieu de trouver une
vie meilleure ont trouvé la mort au
large des côtes
pour ces médecins bénévoles aux aguets
pour porter secours
chaque perte est comme un coup de
poignard au coeur mais tout ça
n'empêchera pas la majorité de nos
rescapés d'assos de repartir vers le
large à la première occasion
j'ai essayé dit cet homme venu du
pakistan il ya un mois il le faut
pour eux l'espoir demeure à l'horizon
est plus fort que la peur